wonderful to have you here thank you so
much thank you so much for being without
love Li warm reception well this is you
know Scandinavians yeah there you have
it
absolutely absolutely telling your album
is called nostalgia when do you get
nostalgic oh my goodness I feel more and
more sometimes I think nostalgic now
particularly because I've now lived
almost you know six decades which is
just extraordinary if there's anybody
here that was born in 1954 maybe you're
sort of thighs with me a little bit but
it's so interesting you know yeah with
one hand went up hello madam you're
still holding what did you I was
listening to the rehearsals from from
backstage when you because you don't
you're gonna sing for later in the show
right um when you rehearse you are so
extremely focused um I wonder how much
does it cost you how much of an effort
is it for you I think that actually you
know when we perform as musicians and
people see the end result of all the
work that's gone into what we're
preparing to do they only see a very
small amount of it and so yeah wake up
when you wake up in the morning like
like this morning is and you know that
elevation yes then do you think like oh
how lucky how lucky I am
or do you think oh no no I don't I think
all the squeeze of the days and
everybody all no no no how fortunate how
amazing to be asked to come on a show
like this and to perform this is an
incredible gift so I'm very grateful for
that see it's your voice that's the gift
well the thing is that it's I remember
III when I was quite young I I sang in a
choir right yes well that was well yes
it was a good idea for you it wasn't for
me Oh
and the thing is that this this
conductor in the choir you have this
idea that anyone can sing and that's not
true is it anyone can sing I disagree
with that but not everyone can maybe
sing as well as a very high standard
let's put it like that and I think any
polite but no but just to say that music
is the gift for everyone and that is the
beauty of of music that it is really
something that we can all enjoy it
doesn't matter our age because you can
be a tiny baby and you love music and
you couldn't be an elderly person who
loves music there's no rules about it
like that and if you don't think that
you have a voice you'll sing anyway for
the joy of being in the shower and
singing freely where nobody can hear you
it's ok
that's how it for me anyway if you if
you were to start today your career
today do you think you would like be the
winner of Pop Idol absolutely not I mean
these kind of these kind of shows are
anathema to me I know for sure that the
process of having to go through that
kind of pressure of competition live on
television with this panel of judges
that are giving you points and
critiquing you in front of millions of
people I think it's very cruel actually
and I don't have this kind of
sensibility that could have dealt with
that I'm a bonafide old-school artist
and we came up through the ranks you
know we start off playing in little tiny
clubs little smokey tiny clubs but back
in the day when you could smoke in clubs
and then you know we used to be able to
do it but and then we go up to bigger
venues and going and driving in a van
through the night and picking up your
own equipment doing all of that until
eventually eventually you you work your
way up but it wasn't lost at a moment
when you discovered a voice there
probably was a moment when I realized ah
I know what it was it was actually
seeing and hearing Carole King and and
Joni Mitchell they were in a way a kind
of blueprint inspirational models role
models for me at the time although I
sort of understood that but I was just
so impressed with them and I fell in
love with their music and and who they
were as women and the words of their
songs and I thought I want to be a
singer
songwriter not just a singer but I want
to be write songs as well and you wrote
quite a few I wrote songs with Dave in
with you Rhythmics obviously that's a
huge huge part of my life and then
latterly I tried to do something on my
own as well yeah and do you have your
ass makes made you very famous there was
a point where you rythmics really broke
through with sweet dreams obviously and
this the record just went up to number
one across the globe I don't know I
think I read somewhere that do you
describe that like being in a bubble yes
can you can you describe the interior of
that bubble it's a lot of to do with
work it is a very work orientated bubble
and you're living to do that work and to
prepare I was talking about that earlier
preparing for that work you know knowing
that when you wake up in the morning you
check your voice first thing how is my
voice today because you know you have to
do a show maybe nine o'clock and you
have to be onstage for two hours dancing
and singing so if there's any little
problem with the voice you have to do
with it straight off as soon as you get
out of bed it's like okay I need to work
on my voice and if you have to see a
doctor you have to see a doctor whatever
you have to do have to do that then you
go to your soundcheck in the afternoon
at four o'clock you check out all the
equipment make sure everything's working
out and then you wait they call used to
call it like hurry up and wait you've
heard of that hurry up and wait it's not
it's wait and hurry up you'd have an
wonkin who can hear that even when you
talk about other things you have an
accident
activists sold in a way and you've
always been an activist what has I mean
and you've had several courses that
you've been supporting HIV and a lot of
different causes did you have a moment
in your life time in your life that
triggered this this activism the trigger
do you as an activist thirsty that
sensibility has always been with me and
my family really on my father's side I
would say that there was a great deal of
discussion around the table about the
injustice of the world okay that's fair
enough but then there always had this
sensitivity about what's going on and if
you
if you're not blinkered then you see it
around you it doesn't have to look very
far it's not even about reading a
newspaper step out in the street you'll
see homelessness you'll see all manner
of things right on your doorstep so it's
a really a question of figuring out how
if what do I want to support how
effective can I be and for me it was
about my gender about being a woman and
also about being a mother and the big
step that I took was a decade ago when I
was in South Africa and I met Nelson
Mandela through the 4 double 664
Foundation and I witnessed the hiv/aids
pandemic in South Africa and was
absolutely horrified by what was going
on there with millions of people
literally dying like flies and nothing
being done about it and this government
causing a bottleneck to access to
treatment it's done it's not like you
you haven't experienced hardship
yourself I mean you you've you've been
open about that losing a child yes many
people do many many people do has that
has that got something to do with your
engagement how's that yes I think of
course having something so profoundly
affecting like losing your baby changes
your personal paradigm also both my
parents died of cancer and I never
thought about cancer until my father
succumbed to cancer at a very early age
of 61 you see so when you have a
personal experience of something and
this is maybe sometimes the silver
lining in the dark cloud that you will
find that when people go through tragedy
and loss when they are able to when they
are stronger they say you know what I
want to do something now because I know
what this is about it's a personal
experience for me
I'm now going to help other people so I
never say prescriptively people should
do X Y or Z that's entirely up to you we
all have our lives to live we all have
our challenges to face but I think
there's something about it's a very
important issue to be feeling engaged
with the world not just your own bubble
you're a private bubble but also the
world that you live in
are you are you also can you be a
challenge to work with I think that
everyone deserves your respect and if
you start to assume that people are just
there to serve you and you're not
grateful for what they're doing then I
think you have a big problem so from
from my perspective it's so I feel
uncomfortable really to be frank with
you this notion of a star or celebrity I
think I'm an ordinary person I have a
gift in music and that on communication
I hope some people love it some people
hate it some people are indifferent
doesn't matter you have to live with
that pretty could you be a challenge for
Dave for there Stuart could I be I was
always a challenge for Dave's - yes
because you know we challenged each
other we were also very very good
friends and so yes of course we didn't
always agree with everything we have
very different styles and so I guess
that would be challenging for Dave are
you are you still close and I would like
to think that we are but we live very
different lives and we live in very
different parts of the world we have
very different pursuits and interests
but I have a deep love for Dave and a
deep loyalty to the time that we had
together
absolutely and way back in the days you
you were a couple and I wondered and are
you a perfectionist when it comes to
love that's a fair question no but I
mean you've had a few marriages let me
put it to you like this my husband who
because I'm married is perfect as far as
on pieces that he's discernible doesn't
matter I was the others are irrelevant
today
volatile PM well I'll tell you something
it is many of us when men and women have
felt disappointed in love all the songs
that people sing and write all the
things you feel something about the love
we're all longing for love we want to be
seen we want to be heard we want to be
respected we want to be adored actually
and if you find that for that true true
love that friend who adores you and you
adore them
and you respect each other that is the
biggest gift and you are so so grateful
for it
so yes I'm I think my husband is
absolutely perfect and I adore him
for all his faults and all his flaws and
all of mine because no one is perfect
we're not I must ask you one more
question before we move on and because I
earlier this year you got a lot of
credit and it was quite surprising you
you got a lot of credit for from the
former manager of Spice Girls
he said I'm Simon he's my Mahajan before
the Spice Girls yeah what he said I
don't think many people know this he
said that the four Spice Girls meeting
you was the most significant meeting in
they're becoming Spice Girls that was so
important that he called you sort of an
architect said that are you quite
honestly I mean I'd have to ask them
what they felt about that but basically
yes I remember it lost it completely
and so many experiences but one of them
was that yeah Simon Fuller who is now
known because of them and because of you
know Idol and all of these things many
many many moons ago was a humble manager
my manager and this is before he became
what he's now you know and he is he is a
great man in many respects but he asked
me if I would meet them when they were
just before before before anything
anything anything and they had just done
their very first photo session and he
thought being the sort of wise older
woman as I was at the thought I was at
the time
I should meet them and guide them into
what you know give them some tips and
give them some mentoring but you see
they turned out to be a completely
different kind of girl girl group than I
thought they were going to be so they
didn't really turn out the way I wanted
them to exactly I mean they're hugely
successful but in my view they obviously
the very inspired by me I think they did
quite well they did quite well thank you
Annie Lennox thank you speaking about
champagne you've you have been called
champagne socially yes well how do you
respond to that
I don't mind this tag I kind of relish
it you know I'm